well dodger town is
laker land on a day where
the dodgers celebrate another victory
they also honored
a fallen legend in kobe bryant today
would have been
kobe bean's 42nd birthday
2-2 comes inside and gets hampson's
strikeout number one
for ross stripling you throw 91 up and
into a right-handed hitter that's gonna
play in terms of perceived velocity
a lot harder so here's chuck nasty
average at 402 coming into today
gets a 2-0 pitch to swat into right
field charlie blackman's going to stay
above 400 for the time being
the two out knock now one of the best
shortstops in all of baseball trevor
story
130 dingers since the start of the 2016
season that leads all middle infielders
in baseball in fact he's the fastest
middle infielder fielder to reach that
mark
but stripling sends him down swinging
second strike out of the first
fella working quickly coming off really
one of the best outings of his career
no doubt we walk into minute maid park
eight innings no runs no walks
when you have a guy who loves to swing
first pitch fastball give him one
but make it your fast ball yes see if
you can get in the chase
any baseball fans wondering that was
intentional for senzitel to miss the
zone
seeger skies the 1-0 drifting back at
the wall it's gone
the ball has been flying out of the yard
at dodger stadium this series
and seeger the latest to benefit it's
one nothing la
corey seeger's seventh of the year
you're absolutely right about the way
this ball
carried you saw that high launch angle
at 39 degrees and i was watching
hilliard the left fielder
going back like he was tracking it look
he's just kind of drifting
and runs out of room that tells you that
was a lot of carry
he can't believe it said to tell us that
i thought that was a fly to left field
second and third nobody out for brendan
rodgers
grounded to the left side coming home is
murphy he's in a rundown tagged out
by will smith two out walk loads them up
for rhyme el tapia
tafia to left field taylor coming over
did not get it to get into the seeger
jet stream [ __ ] hernandez
almost wasn't a part of this rotation in
2020
off-season trade with the angels fell
through while he
and jock peterson that one to the track
bets back for taylor back in it's gone
you kidding me trevor story
has tied the game at one in the third i
can't begin to tell you how impressive
that was i know the ball is carrying
today
but watch him pull his hands in that
pitch is not even
in the strike zone and he gets barrel on
this
remember i said anything in you need to
hit farther out in front of the plate to
get it on the barrel
and like you can tell that he really
barreled it up
because there's no hooking action to
that ball so we'll turn it over for
mookie betts
nine home runs the first portion of his
dodgers career
3-2 mookie left center field
going back as hampton he's out of room
home run number 10 for mookie bets in
the dodgers lead 2-1
never late and mostly on time
fastest hands in the game and that pitch
is designed to be up you saw senzatella
trying to get mookie to chase the
fastball up
earlier and it was just too high that's
right at the top of the zone
la colorado in the fourth
first pitch swinging and another
home run
that's the way to bring us back from
commercial ryan mcmahon it's 2-2
this ball's absolutely hammered it might
have been the change-up that he just
left up yeah it was
ryan mcmahon he's just got tremendous
raw power there's a lot of swinging miss
in his game but
he's got a lot of this too so a two out
opportunity for [ __ ] hernandez muncie at
first
jack peterson over at third
[ __ ] high in the right center field did
you
[ __ ] hernandez
the mustache mojo kicks in and the
dodgers lead five to two
fastball middle of the plate to real
good fastball
hitter it's a good approach as well
stays on to the middle of the field
there you go stash
stash power so with blackfoot on first
story
gives the 01 pitcher ride into right
field mookie betts at the track
jumps and makes the grab well he wasn't
quite sure
if he had another step or not so he knew
once if
the spikes hit the dirt he knew he was
close
so still really learning dodger stadium
and relationship between the wall
and the dirt track so he's probably got
another step
cody bellinger in the dodgers leading
the colorado rockies
five to two in the sixth inning cody
bellinger
[Applause]
good bye no doubt about it
it's a home run bonanza in l.a 6-2
dodgers
he's trying to back door but just got
way too much of the plate to a really
good hitter
just tremendous bat speed
his bat through the zone the extension
the ball is jumping today
at dodgers stadium la happy to see will
smith back and healthy
pulls the hands in for the 1-2
drifting back at the wall another home
run
they won't stop in l.a will smith
joins the party and it's 7-2 it's a
six-run la lead
they don't strike out run the bases max
muncie in the air to right did you
you got to be kidding me that's
six six home runs for the dodgers
who now lead by seven
mookie again it's dinger day at dodger
stadium
i got nothing tom i got nothing
he's got a lot mookie betts is the human
highlight reel
we got all of that one fastest hands in
the game
we see it again